[Música]
boa tarde pessoal
nossa que mostra é muito legal porque
geralmente não faço isso como foi a
minha praia foi apresentada aqui eu
tenho mais duas irmãs que são minhas
sócias e uma delas em relação às
relações públicas então ela faz a sua
parte de falar em público de nos
apresentar de representar nossas marcas
quando tem uma palestra eu sempre fico
né fugindo neste momento
e dessa vez eu estou aqui né é muito
legal e eu entrei no instagram falei
nossa vou palestrar no 1t dex e o que
vocês acham que eu deveria falar dos
meus seguidores acabaram sugerindo
vários temas interessantes que vão virar
empreendedorismo feminino enfim envolve
muitas coisas até mesmo a nossa história
que é algo que eu sentir que tudo o que
ele pediu
eu já compartilha na internet tem muita
coisa sobre mim na internet eu falei vou
pensar em um tema que eu possa ensinar
algo para vocês que eu sinto que faz
parte do nosso dia a dia que é muito
natural para nós nas nossas empresas mas
também não estou acho que ainda não é
tão óbvio pra todo mundo
bom eu vou falar sobre marcas nativas
digitais
vocês têm reparado que muitas marcas têm
surgido conversado com vocês
exclusivamente pelos meios digitais ou
pelas redes sociais
enfim esse é o canal de comunicação
direto dessas marcas e essas marcas
também elas dividem a história delas
você sempre que conhece elas muito
profundamente a ponto de sentir que
sabem participaram da construção dessas
marcas se você se lembra de alguma marca
é com esse perfil provavelmente você já
se deu já participa já se deu conta que
participou de uma marca nativa digital
eu queria aqui uma descrição do que é
uma marca nativa digital pra ficar bem
fácil entendimento e pra frente a gente
vai
aprofundando o assunto o que são marcas
ativas digitais todas elas nasceram na
internet estão 100% digitais mas elas
criam conteúdo de extremo valor e com
esse conteúdo elas constroem uma
comunidade a partir da conversa que elas
têm com essa comunidade
elas criam insights e co criam soluções
com essas pessoas e para vocês
entenderem poder diz que o poder que
existe dessas marcas nativas digitais
eu vou dar alguns exemplos de algumas
empresas que eu gosto muito nos estados
unidos já é bem comum já é bem já
existem várias aqui no brasil existem
algumas mas adoro cheio de clube por
exemplo é uma empresa que de assinaturas
de produtos de barbear e ela foi é
vendida para onde leve por um bilhão de
dólares
a orbe parque é uma empresa de óculos e
foi avaliada por 1.2 bilhão de dólares
ela faz óculos e também co criança esses
modelos com seus com seus clientes e
também trabalha com a idéia de design
enfim há também gosto muito do glaciar
que é uma marca que teve um aporte de
investimento de 100 milhões de dólares e
nasceu da internet
aqui no brasil eu gosto do exemplo da
bruna tavares que criou pausa pra
feminis feminices que é uma blogueira
que criou sua marca a partida do seu
blog e hoje fatura 4 milhões de reais e
é um case de sucesso dentro da sephora
mas antes a gente continuar preciso que
vocês entendam que existe uma diferença
entre marca nativa digital e presença
digital
então a marca que tem uma loja virtual
um facebook o instagram não
necessariamente são marcas nativas
digitais tá e o que uma marca nativa
digital tem quais são suas
características
bom ela tem uma comunidade ela cria
conteúdo com essa comunidade
conseqüentemente ela consegue fãs
fica ela coqueria ela é transparente
vulnerável
ela usa de análise de dados para criar
os seus produtos e conseqüentemente ela
vende mas a venda é só por consequência
não é o foco dela daí gente tem a parte
mais legal que é o que eu quero falar
pra vocês
o que nós podemos aprender com marcas
nativas digitais
a primeira coisa é inversão da lógica de
consumo como é que funciona normalmente
uma empresa vai lá pensa num produto e
ela cria uma solução incrível e ela vai
tentar seduzir os seus clientes para que
eles comprem aquele produto ela vai dar
um jeito de encontrar os clientes e
convencê-los de que aquele produto é bom
olha e ela veio fazer essa venda as
marcas ativas digitais essa mudança na
lógica de consumo é que você não vai
atrás de seus clientes você não tenta
convencê eles que aquele produto é bom
você vai construir vai criar aquele
produto com a comunidade que já existe e
cada passo da jornada do cliente importa
você começa a ficar fissurado por essa e
por essa construção por onde onde a
marca está acompanhando aquele cliente
onde aquele produto está indo então por
exemplo o que ela vai fazer com a
embalagem ela guardava joga fora ela tem
orgulho de tirar uma foto e depois pela
compra aquele produto ela vai pôr nas
redes sociais têm orgulho de falar para
os outros que ela que ela comprou aquele
produto então essa jornada importa muito
e quando e quando você pensa nessa
jornada está pensando na experiência do
cliente que vale muito mais do que o
produto e que a gente está buscando vai
muito além dessa desse produto está
buscando experiência que eu vou sentir
quando comprar o que vai fazer comigo
qual é o meu sentimento e esse
sentimento pode muito além da do online
ele pode se estender para off line é e
não ter medo de ser vulnerável porque as
marcas ativas de tais não tem medo de
ser vulneráveis
geralmente a gente pensa nessa palavra
já sente uma coisa ruim porque eu sou
uma marca e não quero que as pessoas
sintam que eu sou vulnerável que eu sou
fraco o que eu tenho é vulnerável
o que dá a sensação de coisa ruim de eu
quero que as pessoas vejam o meu lado
fraco né
só que as marcas ativas digitais elas
mostram justamente isso elas mostram
esse lado humano dela nesse lado que é o
lado falho e porque elas fazem isso
elas fazem isso porque isso traz conexão
e não é ser vulnerável de ser fraco é
ser vulnerável de ter coragem de mostrar
que nem tudo assim nem tudo está
perfeito tempo todo e essa co criação
que é essencial acontece justamente
nesses momentos de vulnerabilidade onde
você consegue mostrar que aqui eu não tô
me sentindo tão bem vamos juntos
resolver esse problema e as soluções
acontecem você não tá é entregando algo
pronto você está construindo e criando e
compartilham histórias principalmente
começo meio que é onde estavam diz o
presente e o fim vai acontecer porque eu
quero dizer com isso
geralmente quando a gente escuta
histórias de grandes empreendedores ou
grandes marcas de sucesso a gente tem
aquele sentimento de tipo meu deus eu
quero ser igual àquela marca incrível e
olha quanta coisa já passou e quando
você escuta aquela história de sucesso
você vê aquele há aquele processo todo
de sofrimento de desafios que aquela
marca enfrentou mas aquilo é passado ela
já passou por tudo aquilo então posso
contar o que já aconteceu mas essas
marcas ativas digitais elas contam no
presente elas realmente contam que está
acontecendo no agora se o agora está
acontecendo perrengue ela não está
dividindo isso com as pessoas e é isso
que dá essa conexão da com com a
comunidade com o público né na internet
as pessoas se sentem próximas elas se
sentem parte porque você está dividindo
algo que é dar medo de dividir né que
são as suas fraquezas e parafraseando o
val noa os humanos eles pensam em forma
de narrativas e não fatos números ou
equações de vocês perguntam bárbara
porque você tem essa pilha tão grande
por marcas ativas digitais porque você
gosta tanto
marcas antigas digitais porque eu sou é
já empreendeu dez anos e só cofundador
do grupo olha que são quatro marcas
nativas digitais 5 na verdade se for
incluiu tudo olha mas é são marcas
nativas digitais e aprendi muitas coisas
durante esses dez anos tendo marcas que
nasceram da internet e o grupo orna ele
começou com um blog
na verdade ele começou com tudo olha que
era um blog de moda a gente com
partilhava conteúdo de valor
esse conteúdo atraiu pessoas e nós
construímos uma comunidade ea partir
dessa comunidade
nós criamos soluções e produtos então a
gente criou a urna que virou nossa linha
de acessórios depois a gente que orna
fórmula de cosméticos
depois as pessoas começaram a nos
perguntar como é que a gente ganhar
dinheiro com a internet então a gente
criou o efeito ana que ensina eles
ensinam as pessoas como que a gente fez
para criar marcas do zero na internet e
horna café que é nosso café em curitiba
que é uma experiência on off e online de
toda essa construção que nós todas as
marcas no digital
o grupo warner café é um exemplo
interessante de que as marcas ativas
vegetais podem ir para o campo é o fla e
sair do digital e pro flamini
por que a gente é fissurado pelo que
pelo por experiências como a gente falou
no começo então essa jornada do cliente
ele tem que sair do digital uma hora aí
pro fla em bona café é um é um caso
muito massa não é porque é nossa mas eu
acho muito massa porque ele quando ele
nem existia era só um sonho
a gente já tinha uma idéia de fazer uma
cafeteria em curitiba e essa cafeteria
tinha que trazer todo propósito do
itueto que carregava é a ordem o grupo
olha e eu e nossos valores e então a
gente começou a compartilhar com as
pessoas na internet que a gente queria
abriu o estabelecimento físico sem ele
nem existirá só uma ideia e com essa
idéia a gente conseguiu juntar uma
comunidade de 40 mil seguidores e esses
40 mil seguidores do brasil inteiro só
nos ajudando a construir esse sonho que
era uma cafeteria em curitiba e todas as
nossas
mas elas carregam muito de curitiba né
então mesmo que as pessoas sejam de fora
elas elas compartilham dessa dessa
essência que carrega as nossas marcas
elas acabam conhecendo a cidade elas
elas se envolvem junto mas ela se
envolve tanto que elas participaram do
processo criativo desde dado que até no
cardápio até mesmo a paginação que é ter
no banheiro então se sentiam parte da
construção não era apenas abrir um café
agora vou atrás de clientes para ver se
eles querem entrar no meu café e não era
bem assim
elas sentiram parte então quando ana
café abriu o ano passado a gente teve
uma fila de mais de 500 pessoas para
entrar e eram 500 pessoas do brasil
inteiro e elas não estavam entrando lá
porque elas queriam tomar um café ou por
que abrir um café novo é porque elas
eram nossas sócias é porque elas faziam
parte da criação daquele lugar
elas sentiram que elas fizeram parte de
escolhas então não era um café qualquer
o café que elas participaram da criação
e isso que é uma marca nativa digital
elas entraram lá e sentiu nossa isso vi
no instagram e isso aqui hoje de
escolher isso gente é muito muito
sensacional
então o engajamento emocional que essa
vulnerabilidade você realmente falar o
que é você envolver as pessoas que você
conversar com elas
cria uma comunidade colaborativa que vai
fazer essa cocriação que vai criar
soluções porque não não tem ninguém que
sabe a melhor
o que você não tem nada melhor do que as
provas para os clientes para saber o que
eles querem
não adianta vir a empresa se achando a
dona da razão
achando que consegue achar soluções
incríveis mas na verdade é as próprias
pessoas conseguem achar soluções
incríveis pra você e essa comunidade
cobra colaborativa cria esse
compartilhamento social e isso vira um
ciclo um ciclo de colaboração e tem uma
frase que eu sempre uso é na internet
que a gente sempre usei minhas irmãs que
é uma frase que a gente gosta muito e
acredita muito e todo e tudo que a gente
construiu até hoje foi envolto disso que
é
colaborar é maior que competir e as
marcas negativas de tais entendem isso
que a gente não vê concorrentes a gente
vê parceiros
é a gente compartilha o que a gente sabe
porque juntos a gente constrói algo
muito maior e esse o futuro é
colaborativa as marcas nativas digitais
são as marcas do futuro é isso pessoal
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]